um one of the most terrifying statistics
i ever came across was
um one detailing out the rationale of
the united states armed forces for not
allowing the induct you can't induct
anyone into the armed forces in the u.s
if they have an iq of less than 83.
okay so let's just take that apart for a
minute because it's a horrifying thing
so the us armed forces has been in the
forefront of intelligence research since
world war one because they were on board
early with the idea that
especially during war time when you're
ramping up quickly that you need to sort
people
effectively and essentially without
prejudice
so that you can build up the officer
corps so you don't lose the damn war
okay so there's
real motivation to get it right right
because it's a life and death issue
so they used iq they did a lot of the
early psychometric work on iq
okay so that's the first thing they're
they're motivated to find an accurate
predictor so they
settle on iq the second thing was the
united states armed forces also
really motivated to get people into the
armed forces
peacetime or wartime wartime well for
obvious reasons
peacetime because well first of all
you've got to keep the armed forces
going and second
you can use the armed forces during
peacetime as a way of taking people out
of the underclass
and moving them up into the working
class or the middle class right you can
use it as a training mechanism
and and so there's and left and right
can agree on that you know it's it's a
reasonable
way of promoting social mobility so
again the armed force forces even in
peacetime is very motivated to get as
many people in
as they possibly can and it's difficult
as well you it's not that easy to
recruit people so you don't want to
throw people out if you don't have to
so what's the upshot of all that well
after 100 years essentially
of of statistic careful statistical
analysis
the armed forces concluded that if you
had an iq of 83 or less
there wasn't anything you could possibly
be trained to do in the military at any
level of the organization that wasn't
positively counterproductive
okay you think well so what 83 okay yeah
one in ten
one in ten that's one in ten people
and that what that really means that as
far as i can tell is if you imagine that
the military is approximately as complex
as the broader society which i think is
a reasonable
proposition then there's no place in our
cognitively complex society for one in
10 people
so what are we going to do about that
the answer is no one knows
say well shovel money down the hierarchy
it's like
the problem isn't lack of money i mean
sometimes that's the problem but the
problem is
rarely absolute poverty it's rarely that
it is sometimes
but rarely it's not that easy to move
money down the hierarchy
so first of all it's not that easy to
manage money
so it's a vicious problem man and so
it's hard to train people to become
creative adaptive problem solvers it's
impossible
you can't do it you can't do it you can
implement
your visibility but but you can't you
can't do that it's training doesn't work
it's not gonna work in six months but it
could work in six years
no it doesn't work sorry it doesn't work
like the data on that's crystal clear as
well